You're the executive director for the American America First Legal,
correct? That's correct.
Alright. And America First Legal is a member of Project 2025,
which is dedicated to creating
the playbook for the next conservative administration
and what it calls the project pillars. Correct.
We are proud contributors to Project 2025.
Okay. And, uh,
are you familiar with Project 2020 Five's mandate for leadership?
In fact, I am.
Okay. And in fact,
you wrote some of the sections of this mandate related to the DOJ,
correct? Sure did.
And the mandate outlines policy priorities
for the next conservative president,
is that correct?
It does. You've done a great job.
I just wanna let you know.
Alright, so let's walk through some of the provisions of the mandate.
It calls for eliminating the department of education,
eliminating the department of Commerce,
deploying the military
for the use of domestic law enforcement against protesters
under the Insurrection Act of 18 O seven.
It also has
the repealing of Schedule F status for thousands of federal employees
to allow a president to replace career civil servants
with unqualified,
partisan loyalist.
That's probably my favourite of it.
It also prohibits
the FBI from combating the spread of misinformation and
disinformation,
like Russia and China,
who are actively trying to interfere with American elections.
I don't know why or how anybody can support Project 2025.
And I know that there was allegedly a joke about, um,
dictators and whether or not that's funny,
but in In the United States of America,
dictatorships are never funny,
and Project 2025 is giving the playbook for authoritarianism
as well as the next dictator to come in.